[Music]
if you follow me on the Twitter you know
that I'm not a big fan of award shows in
general but all the talk post Golden
Globes this week is about Oprah Winfrey
potentially running for president in
2020 mainstream media is in love with
the idea of Oprah for president and CNN
the New York Times Time magazine and a
slew of others have all already run
think pieces on her chances in just
three short years Hollywood of course is
also in love with the idea the
conscience of lefty Hollywood Jimmy
Kimmel has already said that he's on
board with Oprah 2020 and NBC even
tweeted from their official account at
NBC that Oprah is our next president
though they eventually deleted the tweet
make no doubt the elite class that was
dealt a swift blow by the election of
Trump in 2016
will quickly fall in line if Oprah
decides to make a run for 2020 Oprah has
an absolutely remarkable life story she
grew up in a milling house in extreme
poverty she survived absolutely horrific
physical and sexual abuse including
being raped by her own cousin when she
was only nine years old from these
unimaginably difficult beginnings Oprah
eventually made it to local news in
Chicago and then on to her syndicated
talk show which not only changed the TV
landscape but had a cultural relevance
unlike almost anything in the
pre-internet age every politician
pop-culture icon an ordinary person
doing something extraordinary seemed to
make it to Oprah's couch since she ended
the talk-show seven years ago Oprah's
had many professional ups and downs
continuing to navigate Hollywood
starting her own TV network own which
has in quite caught on doing plenty of
charity work and of course and perhaps
most importantly always making time to
eat bread with very excited strangers
around a fancy table in a forest as for
Oprah's politics I'm not sure anyone
other than Oprah herself has a full view
of them she was a big Obama supporter
during his first two campaigns and I
have no doubt that she falls on the
Democrat progressive side of things how
she Falls specifically on every issue
I'm not totally sure but we seem to be
veering towards a cliff where the issues
will have almost nothing to do
who gets elected the cult of personality
we're building around politicians and
what that means for the health of our
society in the long term is quickly
becoming a massive problem that's hidden
in plain sight
I'm pretty sure I don't have to say much
on the cult of personality that is
Donald Trump
make no mistake whether you love or hate
Donald Trump we elected a reality TV
star a man created by and now hated by
the mainstream media Trump's rise used
all the tools of the media against
itself and that's why right now the
media is endlessly looking to destroy
him they want their narrative and
control back notice the shift in TV
coverage and articles about Trump in the
last two weeks or so it's shifted from
endless Russia stories to Trump's mental
health in most cases the people writing
these stories are the same people who
said that stories about Hillary's health
were conspiracy theories even after she
collapsed and was dragged into an SUV by
security guards that autumn day in New
York City so what we have right now is a
cult of personality Trump versus the
cult of the media this has made a lot of
people a lot of money as long as they
keep churning out articles and think
pieces true or not people do get paid to
this end Trump is their perfect foil he
has no shortage of tweets to send out
and people to mock so we've got a match
made in hell playing right in front of
all of our eyes now back to Oprah for a
moment
Oprah is basically the exact reverse of
Trump even at the identity politics
level she is a black woman and he is a
white man she grew up poor he grew up
rich but more importantly than these she
says all of the right things she talks
about love and spirituality and is loved
by the Hollywood and media class as one
of their own Trump on the other hand is
their perfect enemy as if they had
written the script themselves alas Trump
was one of their own until he became too
powerful and now he is enemy number one
because they've lost control of the
narrative their hope is that they can
win some of that narrative back with
another celebrity who will play by their
rules but I think that this is
short-sighted at best and disastrous at
worst just imagine what kind of insane
polarizing sensationalized lunacy the
potential matchup of Trump verse
Oprah will lead to as we head into 2020
it'll be great for clicks and ratings
but it'll be terrible for ideas and
debate you thought Hillary verse Trump
was polarizing just wait until Trump and
Oprah battle it out in the Thunderdome
on prime-time television sadly it
doesn't look like we'll ever turn back
to being governed as our founders
intended with a limited federal
government and strong states that
empower people to control their lives at
the local level while Trump has done
some good work in limiting the power of
the federal government he's obviously
happy to govern by executive action as
Congress seeds more and more of their
duties to the executive branch instead
of the legislative branch where laws are
supposed to be written his Justice
Department too is happy to step on the
Tenth Amendment and allow the federal
government to trample on states rights
just look at Attorney General Jeff
Sessions decision to allow the feds to
crack down on state's ability to
legalize marijuana so to sum up we'll
have a president that will most likely
be a celebrity whether it's Trump or
Oprah or Mark Cuban or the rock along
with an executive branch that'll
continue growing and growing in power
this cult of personality will
continually put people into office not
on what they believe and whether they
understand or even care about how
government is supposed to work but
rather by what they make us feel and how
they can manipulate us into thinking
exactly as they do that feeling coupled
with the growing power of the office of
the presidency is a recipe for the
authoritarian control we all should be
wary of the only way to fight this tide
of celebrity induced idiocracy is to get
involved now before it's too late either
that or get ready to bow to supreme
leader Justin Bieber in 2024
[Music]
you